So the temporary victory,
it's also something really good to know
about marriage.
It's like you can never win an argument
with your wife,
like you could if you only lived with
her for one day.
Right?
It's like I wanna see you later.
It's like,
no,
she's there the next day.
And then she's been,
she does.
She does remember that.
Yeah,
maybe even more than you remember it,
you know.
And it also might be that she was right
and you just out argued her.
So.
And that's something that's really worth
knowing too because sometimes you know,
you'll have an argument with,
well let's say with your wife and she's
got something to say and it's not very
well articulated.
Same could be true for you.
And so you can just brush it aside,
but you don't want to brush it aside
because maybe there's something there
and if you don't address it then it's
not like it's gonna go away,
man.
It's going to grow.
So maybe you have to help her formulate
her argument,
which is really annoying because you
want to win and you have in this
dispute,
I want to win.
So like,
well,
you're not winning that game.
You're winning the game.
Well,
I think about it as the game of games.
You want to win the set of games that
stretch across time,
the long war.
Yeah,
that's right.
Exactly where that little battles
knocking,
no matter and in fact you should not try
and be right.
If you're right,
everybody knows it's fine,
but there's the worst thing to do is rub
it in and say,
I'm right and you're wrong.
Yeah.
You do that 100 times and then like,
well you're the,
you're the winner and she's the loser.
And then that's great because now you're
married to a loser.
I mean,
you know,
that's.
If you do that 100,000
times,
then your marriage is over and then and
then there'll be hell to pay.
You can be sure of that.